auge in auge mit dem tod jeden tag alle
männer zwischen 18 und 60 sind an die
waffen gerufen worden haaren zum teil
seit wochen in schützengräben aus so wie
hier in einem vorort von auf den keks
bürgermeister vitali klitschko besucht
wie ist es dort für sein land zu kämpfen
für die freiheit zu kämpfen aber auch um
sein eigenes leben zu kämpfen ich habe
gestern abend mit dem ukrainischen
soldaten bogdan schlug im schützengraben
in einem vorort von pias gesprochen
schön dass sie bei uns sind seit wann
sind sie dort und was erleben sie dort
gemacht und als freiwillige haben
klinische streitkräfte und jetzt bin ich
bei kiel
jetzt sind wir alle offiziellen
jetzt kämpfen wir
wann gab es das letzte gefecht an dem
sie beteiligt sein mussten und können
sie die russischen soldaten sehen
ja heute
heute gab
nicht weit von ihnen entfernt
wie verarbeiten sie dieses leid dass sie
jeden tag sehen dass sie jeden tag
erleben müssen
nicht gut wie kann ich das ausdrücken es
ist schwer
denn ich aber trotzdem müssen sie eine
verteidigung unserer ganzen geld wir
kämpfen für die idee für die freiheit
und
das ist schwierig sich daran zu gewöhnen
ich kann nie sagen dass es leicht ist
ich war nicht bereit das gewehr in die
hand zu nehmen ich muss das tun
der familie haben sie frau haben sie
kinder
nein ich bin nicht
ich arbeite ich arbeite der innenstadt
kommunikationssysteme ich war auf keinen
fall weise mit militär vertraut
wie groß ist ihre angst dort ihr leben
zu verlieren wie gehen sie mit dieser
angst um
wie soll ich sagen
damit das deutlich ist natürlich habe
ich angst habe ich angst um mein leben
aber ich habe mehr angst dass wenn ich
es nicht tun werde dann nicht nur meine
mom menschen leiden werden sondern ganz
ganz viele menschen ich habe keine
andere wahl ich muss dieser waffe in die
hand nehmen
wie sieht so eine nacht für sie jetzt in
diesem schützengraben aufs ausschlafen
sie überhaupt haben sie zeit zu essen
nehmen sie uns mit in diesen grausamen
alltag die sie dort erleben müssen
habe ich einige stunden um mich zu holen
aber ich kann nicht sagen dass ich mich
sehr darüber freue aber ich freue mich
sehr aber wenn wir zu viel zeit warten
müssen dicken nach ried schlafen wir
müssen die waage halten oder etwas was
anderes wörter sind wir für eine stunde
wurden wir umgelegt in andere positionen
und wir haben etwas zeit um uns zu
erholen
es würden sie eher vladimir putin am
liebsten sagen
er soll sich ergeben denn wir werden in
jedem fall sieben
wahrheit ist auf unserer seite wir sind
nicht für die tiere und
welchen traum wollen sie sich bock dann
erfüllen wenn dieser alptraum vorüber
ist
ich möchte zum normalen leben
zurückkehren
gesund
sie wollen einfach nur zum normalen
leben zurückkehren jetzt sind sie uns
gerade live zugeschaltet aus dem
schützengraben können sie uns einmal mit
der kamera zeigen wo sie da genau sind
wie das für sie aussieht sie haben dort
jetzt in der nacht aus es gab heute
tagsüber gefechte sie stehen mitten im
krieg dort
[Musik]
etwas beiseite gegangen damit wir uns
jetzt erholen können wir sind jetzt
nicht mitten in kampfhandlungen und
jetzt entweder auf der fläche von einem
werk haben einige zeit um uns zu
erzählen kann ja physischen überzahl
ging ich es ist verboten die umgebung zu
zeigen ja das verstehe ich das ist
verboten und jetzt stehen sie dort mit
ihrer waffe sie hatten vorher einen ganz
normalen beruf wie konnten sie sich
überhaupt auf diese situation
vorbereiten
ich konnte mich nicht vorbereitet ich
muss das machen
ich glaube es ist nicht möglich sich
darauf vorzubereiten
ich bin um klein ich bin ganz normale
meister ich bin kein militärangehörige
sie verteidigen ihr land sie stehen dort
mit einer waffe sie sind ein ganz
normaler zivilisten eigentlich haben sie
angst vor den momenten jemanden töten zu
müssen
ja natürlich aber ich finde dass ich
behalten werde aber nicht ein feind tüte
der auf unser land gekommen wir haben
diesen ausdruck
wenn jemand mit einem schwert auf unser
land kommen dann wird derjenige zum
diesem schwert sterben wir werden bis
zuletzt uns verteidigen
ob dann vielen dank dass sie sich für
dieses gespräch mit uns zeit genommen
haben und wir wünschen ihnen eine ruhige
und sichere nacht
auf jede
ja dass das gespräch mit bogdan er
kämpft weiter wo er zuvor noch nie eine
waffe in der hand gehalten hat